hi I'm Andrea Crawford and I'm with IBM
cloud so today we're going to talk about
cloud native apps and the heritage world
we have our lumpy monolithic apps and in
the new world we have our micro services
living on the cloud if we take a look at
this diagram here we see we have cloud
infrastructure this is your private your
public and your enterprise
infrastructure cloud native apps apply
to hybrid and multi cloud situations we
also have our scheduling and
orchestration layer this layer is all
about control planes like our kubernetes
we also have our application and data
services layer this layer is all about
backing services and being able to
integrate our application code with
existing services that may be available
on other clouds or even on-premise we
have our application runtimes these are
what we're traditionally or
conventionally known as middleware and
over here well that's where we have our
cloud native apps this is the sweet spot
right up here so our application code is
actually designed built and delivered
very differently for cloud native than
it would be for conventional monolithic
lumpy apps over here so let's talk a
little bit about why cloud native apps
can actually leverage benefits like
enabling innovation business agility and
most importantly from a technology
perspective the commoditization of this
solution stack over here so as time has
progressed and technologies have matured
and emerged
a lot of the services are actually being
refactored lower down in this stack this
means that core surfaces are starting to
have a lower center of gravity freeing
up innovation at this level over here so
what are our use cases for when to build
a cloud native app star everything
everything that lives in the cloud
should have a cloud native app design
and approach this means our application
code needs to be instrumented with
things like standardized logging
standardized events and being able to
match those logging and events to a
standard catalog that multiple micro
services and cloud native apps can use
the last thing we want to do is have our
development squads have to figure out
what their log and event messages should
be let's standardize that because we
want to be able to commoditize that as
well
we also need to have things like
distributed tracing when we get over
into the micro services world over here
we have a lot of moving parts this means
we're going to need to leverage services
core to the system like load balancing
service discovery and routing these are
the kinds of things that are
commoditized in this layer here with
things like sto and with the emergence
of newer projects like K native if you
read the tea leaves I think we're going
to find these types of technologies
embedded into this control plane layer
here but there's still more innovation
to come there are other technologies
like Techcon which actually address CI
pipelines specifically for cloud native
apps that leverage docker and kubernetes
and so if we were to recognize the
benefits for cloud native apps and to
sum it all up we are all about
enterprise and engineering at scale
thank you for
in this video if you would like to see
more videos like this you can subscribe
to the IBM cloud youtube channel if you
have any questions or comments drop a
line below